being new member only of the independent
member and nice to see you now I first
went really smoothly cease evacuation
chair now image as a chair introducing
to the most of us are they important
physically to Scott mr.ellerman what
does everybody like to yes I think it
might be an early 22 seconds there are
few new new members so that's a good
idea let's let's start with John in the
middle well this makes it more
complicated but nevertheless John Mason
I'm substituting for councilor kisan
mrs. Carson was okay you have a tentacle
about that little cord I member
Christine mace and I'm substituting
tonight for my son Elliot capacitor
Elliot Mayson you and Peter scholars
you've already said you humble techies
Roger hundred Chris deadly can cancel
urban dragon vice chairman of standards
I'm casa de vivre Eric I've cherished
answers Michelle pearl committee
administrator John Bostock assistant
director of democratic services that's a
joke udine pastor daniel ft
independently understand shuttle castle
i accept oh also deputy leader and I'm
start to choose you for yourself wanting
to open the other it that I'll sweep
into them no personal problems anymore
all right Thank You members Oh in that
case secondly I just get really out the
emergency evacuation announcement so
should we be required to evacuate the
building would you please leave the room
by the door to the fire escape staircase
please hold both handrails in case the
stairs are wet or slippery if anyone is
unable to use his stairs but they please
allow others to exit the room before
they go to the fire escape door where
they can then be given their systems our
assembly point a million public karpov
at the side of the civil sweet please do
not delay your evacuation to collect any
belongings please do not return the
building until given permission to do so
by council staff can I also remind all
the members if they haven't already done
so to turn all the noobs their mobile
phones and may I remind everyone that
this piece will be recorded we start
with gender item one apologies wrappings
and I hang in the office councillor
Elliot Mayson council mrs. iron casar
any other apologies
Oh a bigger pardon we also have
apologies from parish representatives
counselor mrs. Lester bingo and causal
mrs. levy comes to water item two non
members attending castle jury didn't
thank you the minutes of the meeting
held on the functions of April 2016 I
have to please assign those old movies
once killed I should have asked it for
any substitutes I know we have in fact
dealt with a little tweaking officially
I deal with it please do casual Masek
mr. Mason as I said I'm substituting for
counselor mrs. casar you can gouge mrs.
Christine write it as notified I'm
subbing for counseling Elliot Mayson
thank you okay I'll learn the
declarations of interest
case we moved to i-25 local
investigations and determinations and
your summary want to present on no
chairman it's an annual important is for
receiving noting ID by the committee
thank you he was everyone's road just
like a comment children I just think
it's it's um that's very well on this
council parish councils actually there
only being far as if we move to the
recommendation simply that the annual
summary of local investigations and
determinations for the 2015-16 use of
the year we received set of green
six so you report from the system
directed democratic services relation
remember learning and development Thank
You chairman members of screens question
committees last week we are bringing up
some key aspects of the report that are
reflected in the recommendations in a
sense replication end of the week which
other and the reporters in four parts
just to give a light of our prior to
detailed consideration officers were
asked to look at the viability of
reducing the number of mandatory
planning training sessions from four to
three each year currently there are four
mandatory training sessions each
municipal year if it was decided to
reduced to three it could be practicable
to remove the februari session that's by
that time members of the committee would
have received a good grounding in
planning matters the reduction from four
to three per year could have a favorable
impact on the officer resource applied
to training in that that's something the
committee recognized the last meeting as
a factor they'll also remain an
opportunity for
themself adult training you if necessary
and although it's not thought out in the
report the assistant director planning
once appointed would be able to maintain
current policy where newly elected
members have a separate session just for
themselves by resistance right to plan
soon after election on to the council
the second bit of consideration was
around the content and quality of
training sessions felt that there that
could be little tense and more detailed
discussion once an assistant director
planning is in host could be undertaken
and in any event the assistant director
could for instance consult will probably
hold for planning on on on their
thinking on on that training that's just
a thought again it's it's in the
preamble of the end of the report the
third area that members of this
committee were interested last time was
the time of day when members of
preferred training it was felt
worthwhile to just review that aspect
and members of the council were asked
for their views on a number of
alternatives the chart on para to point
10 shows the response is received I
suppose from that alone as the
propensity propensity points took two
afternoons and
things but again that's just an
observation based on the year only on
the child air then there's the question
of incorporating elearning into the
program member training program the LGA
does have a suite of be learning modules
and officers are working with the lgo to
make that available as soon as soon as
soon as possible it could potentially
complement the current training training
provision and again that's just set out
in the report there it was concerned
this committee expressed concern the low
attendance by the parish and town
councils particularly odd bespoke
planning training sessions on page six
point three para 213 it's small a small
penis Morsi that sets out responses
received against their questions include
some commentary on the district councils
approach drawing attention to paragraph
C that suggests that it would be
practicable perhaps for perished
planning training to be in the evening
because that was
well does look to be a clear issue in
terms of the parish experience the other
aspect of the bespoke planning training
for the parish in towns is attendance
the committee was concerned at the low
level of attendance and it's only it's
only a suggestion that the report
indicates that the committee could think
in terms of perhaps suggesting that half
the parishes stroke town council should
be in attendance at the Train units
that's provided the the first attendee
followed parish or town council that
there's no charge against that based on
current current policy and this is
suggesting the recommendations around
that but again it's for the committee so
chairman that's that's the sort of pre
normal up to the up to the
recommendations I imagine the committee
may want to discuss each foundation in
turn the only thing I'd like to add is
the recommendation warm based on the
flow of the report that should include
that members newly elected to the
committee would have to attend the
training session scheduled for May
that's really missing from that
recommendation in terms of weather
reports government but it's over to you
and your committee thank you thank you I
think we'll be here John suggested it
would be easier if we do with each
proposal in turn I have three speakers
are you speaking up on the first
recommendation no it would be the fourth
but that I think
want to be your first recommendation
first of all mr. chairman if I may I'd
like to speak generally on the whole
report I'd like to compliment and John
Bostock for this report because we had a
very detailed lengthy and I think
someone confusing mating around areas of
concern and you have managed to bring
all the areas together with the
information that should enable this
committee to make informed decisions
going forward so before I speak to any
recommendation I would like to
compliment the officer of his work by
Mike oops if you're referring to the
recommendation one apart from the fact
that we need to put a note in there
about the training for new members which
is already mentioned that quote have
known Colin I wish to add on which item
you that is item one it's already been
proposed I believe that we add that in
there that the assistant director would
arrange training for new members with
heartless seal that new members will
only be in them in May so that I think
we have to put in there something that
what we need to provide training should
any new members come to the council
before the well when they come on to the
council before they take part in a
training session in a planning so its
development committee I thought that's
what you said someone said it yes can I
can that be yes I mean that that's the
intent to chairman based on on current
practice in the early part of report
that was referred to an extent there is
currently policy committees policy if
if if there's a newly elected member who
hasn't had experienced Planning
Committee on this council they would be
required to have some training from
assistant director planning and its
really seen as mandatory so like that
that's the additional I think there's a
apply didn't you been to any new members
yes so they have to have the training
but we have we have we haven't
formalized that's it may be an idea to
add that into the first recommendation
so there's a total clarity that we do
expect members to have some training
before they sit on the development
committee but its subject that I put
I've got no comment of that I'm quite
happy to recommend it with other reviews
on you on that anyone unless anyone else
wishes to speak to they want to speak to
it'll budge against it'll just one sweep
it did okay on this longest oh yeah oh
yeah definitely I'm speaking to and
let's flag it for everyone mandatory
okay because that's what the foods were
the first few words are so that's how I
connect it to what I'm going to say mr.
Bostock referred to learning and I can
certainly see its place within a
learning sweet could he clarified for me
as to whether he feels and whether at
this stage anyway elearning could take
the place of a mandatory session I think
personally chairman members that that's
something the committee would we need to
encourage monsters a proposal for any
learning session I mean for instance in
my experience elearning is quite
different from
the type of training that the members
have had there's usually a pass rate
there's perhaps difference or the
stresses around it and need to perhaps
retake and I in the compulsory training
manager training isn't something that
councils have to introduce and it's
often it's clearly a roach or something
that is is it it's right for rockford
and what not sure what want it would
need to be considered carefully so I you
know that's that's what I'd say on that
good comeback so well I kind of agree
with that because I didn't think there
was a proposal at this point and I
certainly agree that it would need to be
looked at carefully because there are
some pitfalls which I've encountered
around elearning and pass rate Sandra
sorts of issues like that so we have to
think very carefully so therefore will I
conclude is that mr. Bostock is
recommending that elearning is a
supplementary for the mandatory training
in planning no no I don't know what he's
recommending yeah I eventually learning
you say I want to find out that you
don't put any really maybe they just
want me into the facility yeah I in
terms of that later in terms of where
the cows has been before on e-learning I
think the furthest without this
committee looking at it and I'm not just
thinking of planning here and in fact
planning might not be the right the
right thing anyway the local Association
I would see anything that they produce
beings supplementary to whatever
training arrangements these committees
got for the council so it would be an
additional optional this is also very
because that would be in the context of
a good training arena but but not not
something in other members there's
e-learning out their members have got an
interesting the subject then I it should
be made available to them but not this
committee would have to consider if he
was going to replace what I've been the
current mandatory training content but
as best you just come back to you were
you proposing that Livia but I to be
seen a slight cooing mr. chair if I may
I was going to propose remember but I'm
going to actually propose another one
because we have any Showtime doesn't can
we do it what it is today well it looks
in with with item three until three you
said where possible for the current
arrangement of afternoon and evening
sessions for member training courses
being maintained now I don't want to
complement things by complicate things
we're taking out of three out of
recommendations at this point in time
and I know that that is the consensus of
the survey that was carried out what I
would say is that for number one yes I
was recommending that the current
arrangements of form mandatory planning
sessions be reduced to through and
should be held in mesa type in November
and that the mandatory training
requirement starts afresh each municipal
year in objection to that what I wanted
to also add these two things that the
training for new members I'm sure mr.
Bostick can work work that satisfactory
but also that as it is mandatory that in
this case there must be often in an
evening offered because if you are
disqualifying people you must make sure
that they have the opportunity to attain
and we have had to as you know we've had
issues well people have had to go to
great lengths to ultra arrangements and
some people haven't managed to because
of the cancellation of the afternoon
session so I think I second title three
as it stands I think itíll one where
it's mandatory training for planning
we must offer those two sessions so I
would like that amended internet one
happy to move that if everyone's ashamed
of it do I have a seconder German get a
couple of things first of us would ask
the e-learning at the moment I don't
think we can go too deeply into because
we don't know the facts and the
suitability of it for all members so I
think that's something for a future
meeting with regards to the castle
Christy Mays was just saying about the
mandatory training having an afternoon
evening sessions if if it's just one or
maybe two new members that have come in
then to set up a complete session may
not necessarily be the right thing it
might be more perhaps we need to make it
a little bit more flexible that those
two members can arrange with the
trainers to come in a given time when
it's going to be more convenient to them
because it seems a bit dull setting up a
proper training session just for two
people for example tell me you didn't
even care if I could go through
something like that might need to be
deal with on a narrow place no I'm sorry
if I can come back from that I'm dr. I
haven't I hadn't quite finished what i
was saying you've misunderstood what I
said okay let me finish what I was sent
me and that brought me threatening now
I've gone there look you've
misunderstood the afternoon and evening
wasn't for the training for the new
members it's for the May September
November sessions that we have to attend
we've always until the last year at two
sessions offered we've always had the
opportunity to have her attend an
afternoon or an evening session the man
quite clear what member yeah at all so
I'm so if it wasn't clear that's why I
said it was an addition from the
bringing 3 over 2 1 no not for the new
the training for new members has always
been done on an ad hoc basis and I
apologize if that wasn't clear I've just
recalled camera was going to say was it
when we were talking about a new member
that's are we referring to somebody this
never been elected before what happens
in the case if it's a member that has
lots to see and they've been reelected
but of course has gone through an
element of training when he's previously
had a seat how is they that treated as a
new member again or how saturated
difficulty there with the determining
how I would apply it depending on how
long that particular member have been
out of office so again I think I would
have to look at it on our capsule and
agile process let's go and anybody else
want to speak to your vice chairman so
thank you mr. [ __ ] speak on on the
recommendation on one up here I've heard
lots been said but very new mind now the
development committee is is only made up
of 30 new members and any substitutes
has to have a training as well and I
would like to see personally the number
of planning training to remain at four
and two of which you have to be to have
two consecutive me to it than it
training has to be attended in order for
members to sit on a development
committee if it was reduced to three it
is still be two out of three but not
necessary consecutive is my
understanding personally I would like
them to stay at the four as I Arniel I'd
like to speak to that particular
statement and I think we've all found
that it's been very difficult for our
officers to actually find resources to
deliver poor training sessions we've
also experienced the fact they've found
it quite difficult to to choose subjects
that are repeated during the year and I
know a lot of members have become quite
frustrated with having
to attend training that is improperly
tailored to their immediate needs very
often will will have a session on
something that's emerging how we really
don't know what's happening and then
we'll come back to it later later in the
year to repeat it or it will be repeated
with the same speculation my my
experience is that that three would be
completely sufficient to to allow people
to function appropriately whether
they're substitutes or members of of the
development committee because you also
got to bear in mind that members do have
the opportunity to read reports were
ahead of development committee if
they're unsure anything they can consult
with with offices or indeed other
members and let's face it there's a
there's also a pretty long briefing the
text place at the meeting itself so
unless concerned about that but I am
concerned about was the matter I just
raised and also when it was arbitrarily
reduced to a morning afternoon or an
evening session only I personally I know
other members found that incredibly
difficult to actually fit in
particularly if you were a member of
development committee and there was this
issue about consecutive training so I
like the recommendation which I've
already have already seconded and it's
been clarified to relate to the
mandatory training other than those
people who are newly elected at any
particular time I also think it should
remain it's free for the reasons I have
spoken up if i may just in other thing
you finish i should gently as i said by
me interview i think we are talking
about in item three I only went is
wherever possible the ottoman
session yes yeah when I was clarifying
yes because i have seconded / change and
amendment that that reflected the fact
that it's a non where possible where
we're talking in we were talking
specifically about planning training but
i would actually make it any mandatory
training because in manager training now
extends beyond comic done beyond
planning so you know I would be happy to
entertain a morning and afternoon
session available to all members apart
from newly elected members and whatever
time there is to make available for
manager training do you want to suggest
the wording amended wording that you
want to i add you on proposing mr.
chairman if I could just say the council
Mason that I accept what he's saying
with the other mandatory sessions but
for licensing for example they have to
get a specialist in so it wouldn't be
possible to have two sessions and I
think we need to concentrate on my inner
on planning this so when the amendment
is as I propose that the current
arrangement of for mandatory planning
training sessions be reduced at three to
be held in may sep tember and November
each year and that the mandatory
training requirement starts afresh each
municipal year with at least two
sessions an afternoon in an evening
session being offered for each training
session and that training for new
members will be offered or a mutually
agree races to knit before they
participate in the planning development
committee which i think is what mr.
Bostock suggested it right at the
beginning and that's that's fine
Michelle we're going to read that back
so when I real cruel
clear on this so it's as it is the first
paragraph afresh each municipal year
with at least two sessions and afternoon
and evening session being offered each
for each training session and that
training for new members will be offered
a mutually mutually agreed basis before
they participate in a development
committee yes so that only relates to
the development committee training the
planning training this isn't fair
because they lady refers to playing
train united one yes yes I think that's
where the embryo unity okay that's why I
said I wasn't trying to take item three
into it--and well yes I see we come
before we take a vote on that amendment
does anybody want tell us when complete
okay all those in favor
again
go on tight to that detailed discussion
on the map delivery of management
planning training be held when the new
assistant director is in post the
contents of each training session to be
discussed and agreed in advance with
portfolio holder for planning just to
clarify that I I'm advised that that is
discussed with the assistant director so
between the assistant director and
portfolio holder nor shall we need a
slight amendment sure that center you
clear we can make sure that's that's
creature yeah so you want anybody have
any queries on that once the range this
is christian nation Thank You mr.
chairman but nothing wrong with proposed
what's recommended there but I think we
have all expressed concern over the
content of some planning sessions in
recent in the recent year or insight
I'll leave it at that and whilst I think
it's quite handy to have a discussion
and agreed between the assistant
director the portfolio holder for
planning I would like to extend that
also to the chair of the development
committee so that we we have slightly
wider perspective from what's being
offered for training rather than purely
on the portfolio holder so I'd like to
add it to the chair of the development
committee as well as the popo do hold of
the planning if there is no disagreement
with that second yeah well i didn't know
it's coming it makes me tense that sense
because the portfolio holder is looking
in particular policy and there is
emerging policy all the time but was
particularly a strong basis of emerging
policy at the moment with the revision
Paul strategy we're at the same time
Development Committee is operational and
as operational needs to prepare current
planning so actually I think that is a
huge benefit anybody have any points to
read that case we'll implement item
three on the basis of the income sorry
outcome not the reduction in happens
wherever possible the current
arrangement of afternoon and evening
sessions for remember training courses
be maintained that's why I don't think
there's any disabilities in fact is that
otherwise what I'm gonna like this very
much just heard the chair maybe has a
style type it doesn't have a suggestive
in each time doing the notice when the
other thing going we've actively because
it went on longer than 40 movie we're
going to suggest maybe doesn't the exact
time might be a suggestive finished for
my plans do we want to ping also say
don't object that's very much in the
control of the members on the on the
training is to him how many questions
and comments they wanted to make so I
think that's within their own there I
think that's right I think that is very
much the case that most of the sessions
do tend to yes my to attend to finish at
the time but they must know I mean so
long they must now removing reason
helmets and last of all it was all
astral that to any agreements house
some finally becoming that indeed
licensing he went on because we had an
extra power when we went down his
council chamber yes and I remember
matically I'll fight friendship he kiss
her from school or something yeah and if
they knew what time was i could have
made other arrangements case i'm just
people well they told you i think that
normally the licensing training is very
honest and we did a little bit awkward
but probably for new members it wasn't
clear enough but that always is the one
that is three hours their restaurant
it's christie listen Thank You mr.
chairman this recommendation has come as
a result of the survey and I think it
was quite good to see that we have got
some information to base that
recommendation on that we're using facts
from speculation but it was very closely
the morning sessions and the Appalachian
did you actually people that with both
was eleven to thirteen so bearing in
mind that in two years time we could
possibly have some different members in
the council can I suggest that this is
reviewed from two years time but as we
can always do that anyway yes but things
tend to get filtered oh I sort of things
do tend to get forgotten if they're not
noted I know we can do it but am I going
to remember in two years time to bring
it up is anyone else I I'll unless it's
a formal recommendation I don't think we
would remember in practice I'm not
saying that we would deliberately forget
i would just saying that we're very
human and there's a lot going on in
Council it was just a point I have no
strong feeling but I just think it would
be good to keep sessions applicable to
the members of the council that are on
the council that at any particular time
whoever they are yeah I think what we
we would have to react to any concerns
that have been expressed which would
trigger a review of it that time if we
wait for concerns to be expressed mr.
chairman we have already then cause the
problem because if people are expressing
a concern there's a problem what I'm
trying to do is we have here a consensus
that suits the majority of members what
I'm trying to do is make sure that going
forward in two years time because we
have known actions next year that we
still have a consensus that meets the
majority of the members and the survey i
don't think i'm sure the office one
officers will correct me but i don't
think it was particularly onerous or
time-consuming survey and for that would
then give this committee information
that if it felt then it was necessary to
act on that information it could if we
leave it until there's a problem we then
have to get the information having those
sort the information we have to wait for
another committee meeting and they're
not that frequent so almost a year would
have passed before anything have been
done implies that also anything like
aren't you perhaps we should impressive
jeremy says the best we can to come a
little bit halfway rather and have a
fixed review that when we do the survey
report reports from after the training
that perhaps it's an item added to that
sheet that we fill in after the train as
to how that timing of the training has
been in it and monitor what's coming in
from that side of things have you
I clearly need to wait my hand a lot
more vigorously and I will do so
assiduously to gain your attention the
situation is that I think it's a fair
suggestion I think it's a fair
suggestion from counselor steptoe but if
we can put a promise somewhere or where
you can just leave it to our offices to
to ensure that it comes back in some
form I wanted to pick up on the point
that counselor ft made I think he made a
pretty good point I think the solution
is in honor in letting members know
beforehand how long a session is
expected to be and I guess we leave it
to members discretion as to whether or
not they have to go before the end of a
session although if it's not materially
earlier than the large part or the
material part of the session then that's
fine but I'd hate it if if members ever
stood up after half and half way and
said I'm going to go now and expect to
get a credit for a mandatory session but
I just I raised that as a you know not
making anything more of it than to say
that if that becomes an issue then this
committee will have to consider just how
long members can be as you know a
session to get an award of having
committed to training which comes back
into a certain extent so what the point
was made around e-learning which was
about how do you know elearning you you
know from the results when somebody's
actually assimilated and understands the
training or not at the present time we
know we don't know anything in terms of
performance anyway I just introduced
opens I don't come here there to head
often and I thought it would be an
appropriate things you just remind
people say the two issues are one the
reminder from the offices and on and on
the annual review of training which is
not a bad idea and to let members know
beforehand what the expectation is for
the training session that they're going
Thanks thank you jen i'm waiting
patiently for a long time at a time yeah
the question i'm gonna ask does it help
your vice chairman is well good will you
guarantee to the rocks 100 on the 21st
of this month i would love to know who
mr. Bostock what percentage of the
parish is actually replied to him with
the every question it but lunch at last
on 202 get in touch of you if any did
bother here we didn't have anything to
write we just have the information that
came out of Rochford hundred meeting no
after the individual parish you stood
taken directly to every boys to John
didn't you should have had mine for more
awful know that for a fact I'm surprised
there's something wrong somewhere down
because i know i perish our kids think
their letter to john no Sookie enough
without that we went out the response
would you have been asking both
embarrass air parishes it seems it was
it was raised for that the roster
hundred Association yeah an hour and I
broke the money raised it will be a vice
chairman of this committee at the Roger
hundred to get in touch with you direct
I don't know Sarah shoes well I get it
quite a lot of letters and notices
trying i don't recall having having had
a specific letter on on that on their
paws
even was sent but the mechanism was it
was through attendance at a demotion
hundred and getting getting feedback
that way thank you bro
you know what we got to do on the 21st
sensor it's not the 21st is in the 14th
only I was 21st in my diary Charlie
speak again think should write does
anybody else want to but still nice and
three by the way till eulenspiegel ice
cream okay so are you proposing an
amendment um I think we have known also
proposing oh you know an amendment but i
do think cancer steptoe has raised a
value point and i don't think that the
review is necessary think if the
officers are happy to make sure that
comes before the committee in a rapid
fashion or on the I have to say I'm just
like it on the phones that we feel in
our fraternity tons of proceedings it's
it could be general forms I've got any
all their numbers on all the annuity I
thought I saw not proposing it because
I'll leave it up to the other members to
decide what they think is the best don't
look like he's just updated on the
object the report form which is chairman
and the chairman thermometer what going
on I mean the officers do report yearly
on and on the on the mental training
program to this committee they could
undertake assume the survey I know every
two years has mentioned it initially it
is for the committee to you know decide
whether they could in every two years
just just trigger that survey just to
confirm I mean the afternoon and evening
fits with best practice that came
through as having the chance of a member
development but nevertheless it's is
that it's a test isn't it against what
actually suits Rochford because the
purple streak learning wasn't in it for
instance so you know it's it's horse's
foot so we couldn't do that channel we
could introduce something that suits
what's been you know
Thank You mr. that's she's a committee
you need you have you there yes
perfectly something you wanted to say no
night afore is what I want to be looking
for it I've waited patiently you getting
value so there are no men win tonight
and three so the recommendation is there
on the basis of the outcome of the
survey weather possible the current
arrangements of afternoon and evening
sessions remember trading courses be
maintained that agreed item for that in
future bespoke planning training for
parish town councils be held in the
evening and only proceed if at least
half seven in brackets of the council's
have an activity in which mr. race their
final so questions really 11 is will the
Train sessions be specifically for the
parish and town councils or where they
be dovetailed on to the members train
and will once we've got this opportunity
that we learning will that be offered to
the parish councils Germany this is
traditionally being training just for
one of training just for the parish and
town councils each year the question of
the role and to be learning i think is
something that would come back to this
committee but it's a possibility that
that might be an availability to those
as well yeah including possibly
that of the body they'll you know the LG
are you would
sorry countess an eventual see around
the corner that's right no problem so is
there any reason why parishes cant
pretend the same maintenance the Kansas
what we've just discussed as a scientist
I think they did space space space space
the final frontier the killer just to
pick up on that point yes in previous
occasions particularly wedding is all 39
counselors that were members of the
Planning Committee aimed his majority of
parishes turned at the same time we
could actually physically fit in the
room and that was that was the issue it
might it might well be a different issue
now there's only 13 members of the
Planning Committee because not all
members turn up your substitute moons
some services so it may be something
that we perhaps need to have a second
thing about think that the my new jersey
won't seem to be attending anger
yesterday I know that leg brace
different dissipate yeah comes over
several common as Christine says an
awful lot digital attend on one meeting
certain yes judge so I think it will be
helpful to the parrises if they do have
a bespoke session because they're not
doing the same job as as members the
development committee are doing or
indeed members are doing in terms of the
policy issues particularly around the
issues of emerging and new local plans
we are you know the district councillors
have to make decisions on development
committees whereas the parishes are
advisory there are sastra constantly so
you're talking about a different
approach to dealing with planning anyway
and I think it will help parasiticus be
honest if I were Parish Councillor you
know faced with you know policy sessions
on on the local
and I think our glaze or glazed over a
lot earlier it isn't something and they
should be involved in a lot but that's
easy very easy to assimilate I think you
have to assume a certain about learning
and knowledge before you start I think
that might be difficult so I think a
bespoke succession four parishes deals
with the potential space issue and gives
them a better shot at what they need to
know and one out and what our council
think they need to know because it could
just be that our offices and our
assistant director could actually help
them in Carolina role as a satiric
constantly and you know some of the
operational issues of getting
information to us and also the extent to
which they want to speak at Antebellum
committee Thank You mr. chair I think I
can see to clarify the point for counsel
Mason and for other counselors that
haven't attended the previous meetings
and benefits of hearings discussions it
wasn't it always has it was this is
about respect planning the issue with
the meetings wasn't the fact they were
bespoke it was the lack of attendance
that was the concern and the Kirk the
bespoke planning has been offered that
if you there was only for 10 days so the
cost in office a time the cost and
arrangement and the lack of attendance
has left this recommendation but it is
and always has been bespoke parish town
planning training Thank You mr. chairman
I should come more often you got that
now I'm a monic not me you just haven't
made one minute Thank You Steven just
one bottle are two writers who of course
is it one area that is asunder
represented
watchu Atlantic Ocean City Council one
area that the parrot is always bring up
is the cost of the training and 4pm
protecting is too much I accept in
respect of planning training if repairs
or one free space that if one member of
the count of each parish concern for
their charge even serve they want to
feel they have to charge for the angel
to place just remember matching
properties of crazy yes we only had for
those where though they had what is it
16 2016 free places I agree I agree that
there should be a minimum number or for
the parish training yes I know what I
know when you sign them parishes of my
view but there are now quite a few new
cancers and those parishes that they
look after all our counselors turn and
one can so that these in the parry see
it on the council for the parish as well
as the tech handsome so but three exit
and the from what I see at parish level
is that is not so much
information coming into the parish when
planning is asked of them to consult and
I for one will always turn up from my
parish then I would do cancer so this is
a part of mine got deemed effort to help
the parish and I suspect that will be
the same for other cancers who are newly
elected so we may not only get four you
may get more than four and would that
instead of just having one session could
they not have got three sessions or
where is that to enable them to have a
broader outlook of the which i think is
possibly two distinct things here I mean
tonight the committee's looking
specifically at the low levels of
attendance at the bespoke training and
whether or not this should be a minimum
figure for that the question of parish
and town councillors feeling that
they've got sufficient involvement and
information around being able to fulfill
their role is probably something that
the new ad planning should have a look
at because there might be a number of
ways around that you know it might well
need me looking at that's the only thing
I'd say on that show person who's not
saying is that we can't explode from the
survey that you didn't job done College
on that it was with other counselors and
not counselors at this present time so
my response is that that's on
yesterday's better paper and we want to
know what's on today's piece of paper so
in other words put that question out to
those cancers or to the parish councils
to give us some idea as to who would
want to do them to come to these
meetings because if you're just
proposing to do this ad hoc during the
year or the next two years or whatever
the case is I may not be able to use
dive but I can put my information or
there but it may not serve the
counselors that might be here for
instance so you've done it this is
yesterday's piece of paper not today two
piece of paper so what's a DS get it out
to the cat get it out of the parishes
see you and wants to get yourself
involved in this debug wasn't too and
indemnity Harry phone we didn't own a
system to Germany the survey of
afternoon and evening the morning was a
survey of mystery counselors as being
the district councils training program
the district council provides some
bespoke planning training
ocean town councils it doesn't need to
think this so it seems to practice the I
suspect that it might be a value to find
out and the maybe we do this I i I'm not
sure but perhaps we should find out from
the parish and town councils what they
were find useful in that bespoke
training for instance at my none at the
moment and that would knock out some way
to you know to meeting your concerns Jen
I'll start with a question I think we're
probably gonna get a partial yes
presumably all the parishes they weren't
when I was on the road for the Senate
pair got 400 Association of local
councils not all the parishes are
represented so I suppose hunger ask the
question are they all now yes good
that's why I thought I get an answer
from thank you in which case there's an
appropriate forum for the parishes to
have on their agenda for that rotten
hungry meeting some discussion as to
what the parishes want in terms of
training on planning which they'd like
to ask the district council to fulfill
and you could care kidding abductor kept
their parish councils and come up with a
prep appropriate numbers so the issue of
making it ad hoc is actually an
advantage to you it's not a disadvantage
so it is think advantage because it's in
your hands
Kennedy can step out before you go
through thank you for having caught you
down this week all right it's Carol then
I happy to be adult whatever I would
said to say in my role as deputy leader
I tend to go out to talk to all of the
parishes in fact i'm visiting the rotten
hundred association as an official visit
is coming thursday and it's one of the
questions that i had we planned to ask
who is why hadn't they be in attending
some of the training that we'd offered
what was the problem and to sort of find
out some of those sort of bits of
information from the parishes direct yes
I think it's perhaps an idea that we
perhaps do a survey of the parish this
maybe that's something we can do
endeavour survey form and ask them to
fill it in there are a number of new
parish councillors I'm not sure how many
new parish councillors are since the
last election but I think there's a
reasonable number perhaps that's
something we don't need to do but I'm
quite happy to report back to to this
committee with you know some of the
questions that I ask when I go out on my
intended visits over the next couple of
two points one I similar parish council
and we're supposed to support the clerk
is all this training one person can go
for a base for we've have anybody else I
look at you they don't spend a whole
week we're also be maybe we can use the
e-learning may be caught thank a vet
says this is what he's going to if
you've got interesting doing the
planning my test or what what is
actually going to consist awfully might
sound more inviting and maybe in my time
I think he's worth spending the 40-pound
to send a couple of extra vehicle
because at the moment we get this
planning there's planning training gosh
road and we go what's happened w know so
i get or we give the mean
jump the only thing that will comment on
in terms of this committee over time and
the training we've got an exhausted
training program as a as an authority
that they actually close to charter
status but it is the district councils
training program for district
councillors and local councils I'm a
parish and towns have a number of
avenues including now the National
Association at dumbo and I hope parish
clerks appreciate in their liaison with
their parish members that it isn't the
district trying to do the mount or
something or that most districts don't
offer the sort of bespoke training that
others council does and and it's just it
i get a slight worry that in the telling
it's somehow seen in a wrong way it is
right that if we're offering stuff to
the parishes and towns it's pointless it
being pointless but but this and
tonight's and and this is the district
councils training program it's got no
remit you know it's not part of the
parish apart from the monitoring role of
the monitoring officer you know your
distinct councils and it's just that
it's good practice but that muscle just
at that chairman
did you want to come back up again i
supply i'm not i'm home interested he's
put in people with red seven people turn
up I'm trying to make you more that more
people would want to turn up for you as
the understand what it's about says all
that reading that seems very interesting
and I've come from monsey and you're not
talk to six or seven people and maybe
talk to 12 or 13 which would give the
officer I'm wasting my time you really
do destroy the battle to the end zone
okay so our God counseled them as they
lie got Gaza steps there's one major
problems the parishes of her happens a
new planning department set up was the
arbor to decision that they no longer
send out hard copies of the documents
then we follow cloud sit there and
sometimes for an hour hour and a half
trying to open the document it's
something wrong with your system that
hafta top there half the time we can't
only documents and this is the
frustration of a lot of the parishes
that we're not you're not listening to
the problems we have I don't know what
whose brilliant idea was to tell you
could no longer hair have hard copies
well we never hard copies through the
years we won't even talk told about it
about it to after our budgets were said
and that's a lot of tight like the pipe
effort for us to full powerful and you
can see what we were coming from a lot
like us parishes a very small parishes
we haven't got vast sums of money our
planning babe a training budget on it on
our parishes is 100 pound that's all
looking of its fair and that's the
problem your project you pricing this
out or die trying it's just kind of say
that I think John touched on it there
that
parishes do have access to training from
other sources and I think of the
organization music national association
of air games so they do have other
training opportunities and they're my
particular parish we've had a number of
people have gone on to that because they
they prefer to go that direction rather
and come to us so we're in a complete
competitive market that's so that's just
a fact of life I'm afraid I guess you're
amazing I'm going to defer accounts
understanding because I want to be
democratic each other yes eg level what
Paul said about the amount of money is
available and the fact they turn the
counselors dug in any reimbursement on
the travelin why have you to go out to
dumbo and unless there is wild rather
come to the sensibilities to get
information because it's so much easier
for us to get to come here and then he
is to go all the way to dumber and that
is possibly very young but there is
parking there but you know it's sort of
a bit more difficult to do that but yes
I do feel that perhaps I mean the more
if I was to do it which I would do in
any case I've got twice the bubble if
you don't talk to two bites of the
cherry so I can do it through our DC as
a counselor and I could also do it as a
parish cancer so that little bill
emphasis on top them we recycle if you
like put it back in again green to get
it in there so you've got it you know
what you do it sort of thing is a great
idea okay that's done yes thank you um I
don't one ones ones of a beer in any way
critical but I really think if the
Rockford association of local councils
is going to work then that's the
appropriate forum for the parishes to
work out together really want what
planning support they really need I know
for a reasonable fact there are there
are some very experienced councillors
all the parishes who know more about
planning than I do so I Ike and then
there are Clark's who have also spent a
long time learning their trade and in
particular participating in planning
staff free consultation and I kind of
think that I think if the rut for the
socio and local councils boots is on
their agenda they can really work up in
other parishes what we really need and
to grow it to an extent what they can
actually provide to themselves again
it's a it's a cost it's a cost benefit
because it's free also I'd put it to you
could cook the parishes not ask now to
send a traveling trainer instead of you
wold having to go to down though it's
it's obviously you know if 14 parrot is
important we're all waited um no is it
sounds like a song with me it would free
man welcome to download yeah I forget
I'm not going to join United
that's dreadful a lot I've talked about
it that you're 14 of your winter damn
know it would be it would be more
expensive than one trainer coming from
down there so I thought there's some so
you know John Bostock has properly
pointed out you know that we have a
district planning we have a district
training program which we are trying to
assist the parishes with they don't they
seem to have a problem with it we're not
sure what it is we've got counselor
steptoe is going to go and ask them and
I think the ruptured association of
local councils can can actually do
something here to help really resolve
reconcile and maybe point in the right
direction that they have to do with them
deal with the training that's needed
because we do have regular meetings with
parish and town councillors namely oh
yes I mean this is something which is
why i'm saying i can't understand how
we've got to this you know feeling where
they you know you've got parish councils
here some to letting people as well and
they say there's a problem well I think
those problems you know could be
elucidated a lot easier than around this
table because you know we're a little
frustrated because we're trying to help
you but we don't know how to sew there's
something in help yourself you know
you've got a great forum for that I used
to be on it as a parish councillor I was
at representative as a district for it
for a little while it's a very very
useful body I've been feeling client to
use it I must confess I'm beginning to
feel that way they work we're doing our
best to offer what we think what we
think there they want we think they want
we may not be getting absolutely right
they coming back to the same no we're
not happy with that captain Christie
motion Thank You mr. chair I think I can
counselor mr. Mason his roughly said but
I was going to say but there's two main
issues here we we're talking about
recommendation for so if we focus on on
that the main issue is that we are
trying to provide a doubt cost a
training session a bespoke planning
training session for parish and town
councils and we have done that for some
time and it has been grossly under
subscribed it costs us money it takes up
obvious of time and I think the proposal
in as far as it goes on that we
procedure that only at least half seven
being like this this is at no cost of
the parishes is it is a foul need one
but the other point that seems to be
carrying around the floor and that this
is the second issue which isn't in the
motion is that the suitability of that
bespoke training and correct me paro and
i think the consensus here seems to be
that the root referred association of
local councils which you're saying is
meeting the 14 so is ideal if you if you
could discuss it then you've got the
deputy leader going around and getting
information if we can have all that
information as to what the parishes in
the town think is the suitable will
content then that's something we can
look at our next meeting at the moment
we're here in the dissatisfaction but
we're not hearing anything positive back
we're not so you're not telling us what
you want you're telling us what you
don't want which is what's being offered
so my suggestion would be that all right
the motion for as it stands is fine
because it doesn't affect the content of
the training sessions that we're
offering but the content of the training
sessions the perhaps we can have some
information and feedback from the deputy
leader and the parishes five perhaps the
ruptured associate of local councils so
that the next meet
that communicate and perhaps we can
satisfy the other half of the training
session if you like rather than the
attendees and the timing of it but the
content of it and I don't think it's an
important point that if we are offering
something is actually something that's
wanted to [ __ ] is coming on that yes I
think once the information is
particularly the planning side of things
that whoever becomes the assistant
director for planning feed that directly
into them and they need to sort of look
at the way the training of the parish is
one speaking from my own parish in
particular we're sitting around the
table here we've got a number of parish
councillors as well as district counters
we're all pretty committed as counselors
and we put ourselves out to go and find
out these things I can think of a number
of parish councils of my parish
therefore the cup of tea rather or
anything else so so I think there's a
certain amount of that needs to be
resolved we took at the parish level
anyway Thank You Jerry yeah tell me that
if we can improve documentation as to as
you say but what easing the content of
the meetings and that sort of thing and
that be crying unfortunately this past
year we've had several people that video
and then one death in parish and them's
on the council and at the moment one
personally he's sick at the moment so a
parish is very unreliable global cancers
I'm trying to pick up the Condors bring
them all to get bring it together sort
of thing so this is a reasonable I'm
here that's reason why I'm speaking said
on no thank you
if I know more never wanted to speak
let's proceed with the recommendation
this in future bespoke planning training
for parish straight town councils of be
held in the evening and only receive at
least half seven brackets other councils
have hurt ND as very in one against good
thank you you've got the extra just just
observation will come out in the minutes
that there be some consultation through
the deputy leader of the parishes to
combat the next community to try and
find something that super parishes thank
you well that'd be the last item using
thank you all for coming